so good to see you now
i mean i can i saw her over there she
was already having a proud mama moment
she's definitely gonna cry very soon
well being here tonight
and thinking about what this would mean
to your dad would he would be losing his
mind
but also at the same time he'd be like
duh
because that's how much he believed in
me you know yeah
so uh yeah this is
absolutely insane uh no words
i see you already already i know
it's an emotional it's it is really
emotional i mean the song that wolfie
wrote is just such an absolutely
stunning gorgeous
song and um it's really beautiful that
he was honored for it and for
songwriting because that's the first
thing that really stuck out to me is
like wolfie you're a songwriter that's
the hardest part of being a musician
okay who's that they're embarrassed i
can't no i don't know but listen this is
a good musician too if there's any night
you can let mama have this it's this
night because
it is such a special and she's right
being a songwriter is the toughest darn
thing to do for a musician yeah it's uh
it's certainly uh insane to be in the
same category as a beatle and dave grohl
for songwriting so uh that's why it
feels like i'm dreaming this right now
so now i see you've got her hand held
tight
i love this love i love it the only
thing that makes me look good out here
if it was just a picture of me it
wouldn't look nice oh how bad are you
so
proud so happy to be right here with him
oh listen you're about to make me cry
valerie i know i know i didn't even
have tissues i don't i forgot
we have to give give valerie some you
have tissues michelle has to michelle
thank you this is i mean i'm not going
to have any eyelashes but okay here i'll
give i'll just give you the rest because
i know you're going to cry too
thank you so much
valerie
i think we all hope that our children
grow up and do big things and as a
parent there is nothing that will get me
like my child doing something right
anything else that will get you like no
no all i can say is in spite of me and
ed we got this and i am so proud
you know i got to ask you because i it
was so cute and it was a viral moment
when kylie jenner came out and said oh
no
the child's name is no longer wolf
i think it was a joke i was the only
person who could make that joke really
um and i just i i was maybe more worried
about anything that there would be a
bunch of uh
fans of there's not much crossover
between my fans and their fans and
they'd probably be like oh way to steal
this kid's name and it's like i'm 31.
yeah i don't you know so i just i don't
actually care yeah there aren't too many
of you guys the wolf blitzer wolfgang
puck you like not too many of you guys
but yeah you're right you were you took
that first you took the moment to make
the joke and it looks like some people
thought it was funny it was hilarious
who are you thinking you want to work
with next and who do you want to write
for
man i haven't read enough wrote enough
for myself yet i think i need to to
figure out who i am more before i start
to collaborate with others well those
grammy the grammys are about those dream
collaborations though wolfie so so who
is that it's always been a dream to to
collaborate with somebody like like dave
grohl yeah foo fighters or something
like that he's like the main inspiration
for my whole project
yeah
and they're still dealing with the pain
of losing taylor which is so it's uh
absolutely terrible i got to meet him
once and he was such a phenomenal dude
we've been we're on tour right now we're
playing a song a foo fighters song in
his honor every night so it's just like
the least i can do
you know have you thought about it all
what happens when the envelopes open and
you hear your name
i'm not sure i'll be listening just
because it's just crazy to be here i
think if it does end up happening
and then
we'll see what happens
you know
valerie i really just want to walk and
hold your hand i really honestly i just
want to walk and hold your hand it looks
really long can we do the rest of it
because i'm not going to make it i just
want to sit down
and wait for the award
this is a this is a huge night be
present in it you know what i'm saying
take every moment absolutely absolutely
you